joining us on the line is Professor
Walter Williams he's a professor of
economics at George Mason University
author of over 150 scholarly articles
and 10 books professor Williams thanks
so much for joining the show really
appreciate it thank you for inviting me
so why don't we begin with the broad
narrative that's being drawn about the
United States right now which that the
United States is systemically racist
it's always seemed to me that this is
very vaguely defined if if by
systemically racist people mean that
history has consequences and that
redlining in the 1960s makes a
difference in terms of wealth gap today
that's obviously true but if the idea is
that America's systems today are racist
or that it's institutions today are
racist or that most Americans today are
racist I think that's false what do you
make of the claim that America is
systemically racist and that inequality
between racial groups is presumably due
to inequity well I don't think you can
get very far you can't offer a lot of
evidence that that we're systemically
racist or there's institutional racism
in our country in the I think one of the
things that people need to know is that
at least for black Americans the civil
rights struggle is over and it's one
that is at one time black Americans did
not have the same constitutional
guarantees as everybody else but now we
do now that the fact that the civil
rights struggle is over and one does not
mean that there are not major problems
but they're not civil rights problems
they don't have anything to do with
racial discrimination which is not to
deny the existence of residual racial
discrimination so professor Williams
there's been a lot of talk about police
racism or systemic brutality inside
police departments it seems to me
there's an argument to be made about
root ality inside police departments and
training perhaps or bad cops being
protected by police unions but the
notion that the police are systemically
racist and are targeting black men
specifically what do you make of that
argument well of course there as you
said that they're they're policemen who
do not do their job do not take their
oath of office seriously enough but the
the problems that that policemen have
particularly with black people is just
the the crime rate the you know overall
slightly over
the sound of the homicide victims in the
United States are black and and and it
turns out that the the perpetrators are
90 some percent are black so the the the
problem with the problems with the
police pail small in comparison you know
it just just take the case of Chicago
Chicago there's a person shot every
three hours and a person killed every 14
hours and and so far this year there
have been about 280 people shot and
killed and and most of them are black
and by blacks in Chicago
the police have killed three people so
if you're concerned about black lives
well who should you pay most attention
to is it seems to be not what the police
are doing in Chicago but what what other
black people are doing in Chicago so
professor Williams one of the things
that seems to be going on in a lot of
these discussions is whenever you talk
about inequality in terms of any
statistics between black and white it's
immediately chalked up to racism and if
you cite the fact that for example
there's more violent crime in the black
community than there is in the white
community in for racially not
intentionally intro racially then this
is somehow chocked up to the results of
racism so there's always sort of this
receding line of argumentation where if
you point out that people today are
acting violently well that's the result
of historic injustice and racism in the
past which again is sort of a vague
argument because it seems to me weird to
suggest that a black person killing a
black person in today's inner city is
the result of Jim Crow and racism as
opposed to the decision by a black
person to kill a black person in the
inner city but what do you make of the
argument that racism at root can be can
be sort of blamed as the as the cause of
today's inequalities well I think that
for a lot of young people they just
don't have the historical background but
I'm I'm in my 84 85th year of life and I
grew up in the slums of North Alafia we
did not go to at that time we did not go
to bed with the sounds of gunshots the
people most people left their doors open
and until the last person was in I had a
number of friends I just knock on the
door and somebody holler come in and
there are no bars at the window there
the and and other attributes about the
black community is that the my sister my
father deserted my mother and sister and
I went I was three and she was two but
and and so we're lived in richard
richard allen housing project in north
Alafia and we were the only kids in the
neighborhood that did not have a mother
and father in the house today it would
be exactly the opposite so and if you
look at the black family structure in in
1880 and it's in what I give these
statistics in one of my books in 1880
the 85 to 85 to 95 percent of black kids
lived in two-parent families today we're
much further away from slavery and less
than a third live in two-parent families
if you look at the legitimacy rates
today hello gentlemen see rates among
black is seventy five percent and among
whites is slightly over 30% but if you
go back to 1940 the illegitimate rate
among blacks was 11% and that among
whites is 3% and so it turns out that on
a lot of measures of I don't know
socio-economic characteristics blacks
were were were better off in terms of
family structure and and and and
violence at in earlier times which is
not say well I'm going to go back to the
old days where there's that was gross
racial discrimination in our country but
I think that a lot of things that people
are blaming on slavery and
discrimination
we just can't it just doesn't cut the
mustard unless you say that this stuff
skips a generation or two so professor
Williams when it comes to you know
solving disparities it seems like what
what you're suggesting is that the best
way to solve a lot of these disparities
is for individuals to make a decisions
in other words marry your marry the
mother of your child
graduate high school get a job and
that's a fairly unpopular message these
days even though it's pretty obvious
that a lot of these disparities are
indeed responsible for the the final
income or wealth disparities that are
that are continuing I mean they're
they're fairly good studies that have
been done that suggest for example that
if you are a black woman who's growing
up in the in the higher economic
socio-economic group high-income groups
and then you are earning the same as
white woman but a white man a white man
and a black man growing up in that same
group have wildly disparate outcomes
which suggests that racism isn't the
problem it's actually personal activity
particularly among young black men that
that that's been that that message has
been treated as a racist message rather
than what it is which is in my opinion a
message of hope which is if you make
good decisions in a free Republic you're
gonna do well in a free republic it
seems like the popular message these
days is the Michelle Obama message that
you just gave to a bunch of people
basically saying no matter how hard you
work you're never gonna get ahead
because there are too many people
seeking to keep you down yo yeah and
that's an important thing to tell our
people I know when when I was a teenager
my mother used to tell me and my family
say look there's racial discrimination
and if you're black get the try harder
you have to get to work harder and and
that was the message and and there's
also always a message of hope but if you
look at some of the inequalities you
they're unavoidable for example in
Baltimore in the city of Baltimore this
is this is a feature in other major
cities as well at 13 and 13 out of the
39 high schools in Baltimore not a
single student tested proficient in
mathematics and only 3 percent tested
proficient and reading and if you look
at other the six other schools only 1
percent tested proficient in math and
and and across the city only 15 percent
tested proficient in reading now and now
these kids graduate from high school
they give them the diploma which is
fraudulent in the first group in the
first instance but but the but here's
what a kid will say he'll say he'll
graduate from let's say Frederick
Douglass High School in Baltimore and
he'll try to get a job
and he'll say well JD look this way guy
he's moving along faster and he's being
promoted faster than I am and I have a
high school diploma and he has a high
school diploma so the reason why we're
treated differently is because of race
but see the the black kid does not
realize that his high school diploma is
fraudulent that that his his training is
highly deficient and so but however he
doesn't realize that and he'll blame the
any difference in treatment on racial
discrimination professor one seems like
that that is sort of the widespread
perception is that because the narrative
these days is that all inequality is due
to race that any sort of con founding
factor is removed from the picture and
this happens with policing to the
commedia to Adam Carolla he makes the
point that if a cop is a jerk to a white
guy the cop that the white guy just
assumes the cops being a jerk if a white
if a cop is a jerk to a black guy then
the black guy may rightly or wrongly
assume that the cop is being a racist
the the misinterpretation of motive and
the constant media drumbeat that every
every sort of disparity is due to
discrimination makes for an inability to
solve problems it seems I think I think
you're absolutely well they were
absolutely right and we have to get down
to the the basics of their name what is
the cause of the problem now and you
know what a lot of people don't don't
realize is that if you look at black
people as a group you'll find that as a
group black Americans have made the
greatest gains over the shortest period
of time over some of the highest hurdles
than any other racial group in the
history of mankind and and here's the
evidence for that is that in 1865 at the
end of the Civil War neither a slave nor
a slave owner would have believed that
that blacks could make the kind of
progress that we've made all the in a
little bit less than a century and a
half and and the progress is is that if
you added up the income and spending
that black Americans and just thought of
us having our own GDP we would be in the
top 20 nations in two
of a top 20 richest nations it was a
black American who was the head of the
world's mightiest military : Powell
we had a black or mixed-race president
some of the world's most famous
personalities are blacks and so what I'm
saying is that in in 1865 neither a
slave nor a slave owner would I believe
these kind of gains were possible and as
such they speak to the morale the
intestinal fortitude of a people but
just as importantly it speaks to a
greatness of a nation such as United
States that is these kind of gains could
not have been achieved anywhere on the
faces earth except in United States now
I think a lot of people ignore that
great progress that black Americans have
made and and and play the blame game and
play the race racial discrimination game
instead of looking at the hard facts
that you and I are talking about
professor Williams professor of
economics at George Mason University
author of over 150 scholarly articles
and ten bucks professor walls rooms
really appreciate your time sir and
thank you very much
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content